monsieur le Premier Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur général
nous sommes heureux de vous retrouver
monsieur le Premier Président pour nous
présenter comme chaque année le rapport
de la Cour des comptes
sur la situation et des perspectives des
finances publiques je salue également
toutes les personnes qui vous
accompagnent et notamment madame la
Présidente de la première chambre
la situation comme les perspectives sont
plutôt sombres dans votre présentation
vous soulignez que le déficit public
devrait augmenter en 2023 pour atteindre
4,9 points de PIB en effet je note que
le déficit de l'État lui seul atteignait
déjà 107 milliards d'euros à la fin mai
2023 soit 25 milliards d'euros de plus
qu'à la même date en 2022 vous
considérez que l'objectif de ramener le
déficit à moins de 3% du PIB en 2027
demeure atteignable bien qu'il soit
fondé sur des hypothèses
macroéconomiques optimiste d'une façon
générale je crois que nous serons tous
intéressés de connaître votre analyse
sur les écarts déjà observés entre le
projet de loi de programmation
des finances publiques examinées à
l'automne dernier et les perspectives
économiques et de finances publiques à
moyen terme
votre rapport mais également l'accent
sur la procédure de revue des dépenses
publiques à laquelle vous apportez une
contribution approfondie vous soulignez
par exemple que certaines aides ne sont
pas suffisamment ciblées peut-être
pourrez-vous nous donner quelques
exemples vous considérez que le volet
performance de la Golf devrait être
largement révisé notamment en publiant
massivement les données produites par
l'administration il reste à savoir ce
que le gouvernement retiendra de cette
revue de dépenses car peu d'éléments ont
filtré jusqu'à présent
je vous rappelle que cette audition
c'est le premier président est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et je vous laisse
maintenant la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Jacques Claude Reynal monsieur général
sa Jean-François Husson mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci de m'avoir
invité aujourd'hui une fois de plus pour
présenter le rapport de la Cour des
comptes sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques ce
qui est un moment important pour la Cour
des comptes et pour ces magistrats que
je sais comme moi pratiquement attaché à
la mission d'assistance au Parlement je
ne cesse de répéter que nous sommes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
votre disposition et vos alliés je crois
dans ces débats je souhaite saluer
l'ensemble de ces artisans je suis
arrivé ici avec une équipe importante
par la quantité surtout par la qualité
avec sa tête madame Karine Camby
président de la première chambre ses
équipes notamment Emmanuel genisini
conseiller maître qui fut contre
rapporteur de ce travail Stéphane Guinet
qu'on se mette en service coronaire
rapporteur général Olivier Waze
auditeur cette année le rapport sur la
situation et perspectives des finances
publiques nous appelons le RSP porte des
messages que je crois pratiquement
important sur l'état toujours dégradé de
nos finances publiques sur la nécessité
de nous projeter sur une trajectoire de
redressement alors que le contexte
économique a fortement évolué et pas
pour le meilleur depuis l'année dernière
la croissance ralentit et même si la
France contrairement l'Allemagne semble
avoir échappé la récession le dynamisme
exceptionnel des rentrées fiscales qui
nous a il faut le dire bien aidé en 2021
et 2022 ne se répétera probablement pas
une troisième année consécutive du côté
des dépenses l'inflation et la hausse
des taux d'intérêt augmente la charge de
la dette fortement qui mobilise une part
croissante de nos ressources je l'ai
déjà dit je le redirai
si nous voulons préserver notre
souveraineté budgétaire si nous voulons
restaurer nos marges de manœuvre pour
financer la transition écologique si
nous voulons investir dans des domaines
clés il est indispensable d'assainir nos
finances publiques le désendettement
vous le savez bien
n'est pas une fin en soi mais c'est un
impératif pour les générations futures
et sa raison d'être c'est de préparer
l'avenir je sais que cette contribution
est attendue d'autant plus que je dis
l'occasion d'en présenter certains
éléments
aux acides et finances publiques le 19
juin dernier car nous allons maintenant
passer aux travaux pratiques et je
dévoilerai demain matin une dizaine neuf
exactement notre thématique sur des
grandes politiques publiques sur
lesquelles il me semble que nous devons
collectivement réfléchir
le rapport que je vais vous présenter
maintenant comporte quatre chapitres
dont les trois premiers sont assez
traditionnels pour un tel rapport il
porte successivement sans surprise sur
les résultats 2022 sur l'exercice 2023
sur la trajectoire plus réelle tracée
par le programme de stabilité 2023-2027
tandis que le quatrième je m'y attendais
un peu plus donc et plus novateur c'est
qu'une contribution transversale
méthodologique de la Cour des comptes à
l'exercice de revue de dépenses qui
propose une grille d'analyse de ce qui
est essentiel à mes yeux c'était la
qualité de la dépense publique illustrée
par de nombreux travaux récents des
juridictions financières ici autour de
ces quatre temps que je vais organiser
mon propos en allant vite sur les trois
premiers d'abord le rspfp et l'occasion
de constater à nouveau que le déficit
demeure très élevé en 2022 quelques mots
sur le quoi qu'il en coûte dont nous
devons
définitivement la fin on trompette
sa sortie depuis longtemps l'année 2022
devait être le moment mais la crise des
prix de l'énergie la guerre en Ukraine
ont empêché ce retour à la normale du
niveau des dépenses publiques et
l'inflation a atteint des niveaux que
nous n'avions plus connus depuis les
chocs pétroliers l'activité économique
enfin a ralenti fortement en 2022 le
gouvernement a choisi et ça se comprend
de protéger les ménages et les
entreprises grâce à des dispositifs
comme le bouclier tarifaire comme les
primes à la pompe ce sont des choix qui
ont permis de sauvegarder le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages de préserver la
compétition des entreprises d'atténuer
le choc d'inflation mais ils ont
entretenu du côté des finances publiques
une incontestable et force dynamique de
dépenses et ce faisant ils ont très
fortement pesé sur notre déficit qui est
resté vous le savez élevé
très connu ces 4,7 points de PIB si je
le qualifie d'élever c'est bien sûr en
soi mais c'est aussi en comparaison de
nos autres partenaires de la zone euro
et c'est enfin du fait que nous avons
bénéficié en 2022 de facteurs
conjoncturels plutôt favorable qui
aurait dû permettre de le réduire
d'abord les mesures de soutien liées à
la crise sanitaire et les dépenses de
relance ont diminué de 50 milliards
d'euros ce qui est considérable et si
les dépenses énergétiques n'avaient pas
pris le relais ça aurait ramené le
déficit à un niveau nettement plus
satisfaisant d'autre part et comme en
2021 le dynamisme spontané des recettes
publiques étaient exceptionnelles au
point que je le signal ici c'est
intéressant je crois malgré la poursuite
de des baisses d'impôts qui ont atteint
50 milliards depuis 2017 le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire atteint un
niveau historique en 2022 le plus haut
de l'histoire 45,
100% du PIB il n'y a jamais dû jamais eu
un tel niveau de notre pays pourquoi le
déficit reste-t-il si élevé malgré des
facteurs conjoncturels plutôt favorables
et bien il s'est passé que
ce déficit reste pour sa plus grande
part de nature structurelle 4 points de
PIB et ça veut dire aussi qui ne se
résorbera pas du seul fait du
redressement de l'économie quand je dis
qu'il faut penser à la dépense c'est
parce que il est vain d'attendre je ne
sais quel retour au Trente Glorieuses
qui d'un coup effacerait un déficit qui
n'est pas conjoncturel les concepts et
les indicateurs utilisés dans le cas de
la gouvernance européenne sont en cours
de révision mais je rappelle que c'est
difficile structurel
qui est l'élément clé du pack de
s'habituer de croissance devrait être
beaucoup plus bas l'objectif de moyen
terme fixé par la LPFP
2022 était de moins 0,4 % et la cible
pour 2022 de -08 % on en est très loin
on voit à quel point les cicatrices de
crise sanitaire sont profondes
conséquence du déficit élevé la dette
publique l'état 111,8 points de PIB elle
reste très supérieure à son niveau de
14,2 points de PIB de plus elle est
passée de 2375 milliards d'euros en 2019
à 2950 milliards en 2022 soit une
augmentation de 575 milliards d'euros en
trois ans et on sait qu'elle vienne
passer les 3000 milliards d'euros
voilà pour 2022 constat connu mais je
voulais essayer de donner quelques
éléments
d'analyse supplémentaire j'aurais
maintenant les 2023 qui aurait dû être
la première année d'une trajectoire mais
d'après les prévisions même du
gouvernement on peut craindre que ce ne
soit qu'une année blanche ou disons si
on veut être plus aimable de transition
en matière de redressement des finances
publiques bien sûr les incertitudes
économiques demeure forte le déficit non
seulement ne se réduira pas
mais il devrait peut-être même repartir
légèrement la hausse comme poussant à
2024 le début de la décrue
nous avons eu la chance de bénéficier
d'un hiver doux sans rupture
d'approvisionnement sur le gaz les prix
l'énergie ont diminué très fortement
depuis le début de l'année 2023 l'année
de mort toutefois marquée par de
nombreuses incertitudes à la fois
économiques et politiques et donc
financière dans ce contexte notre
croissance je cite président du
gouvernement devrait atteindre 1% ce qui
est un petit peu plus d'après le hcfp et
le consensus des économistes que ce qui
est probable c'est 06 mais disons que
bon c'est pas impossible
s'agissant des recettes publiques elle
devrait marquer cette année un être
ralentissement en terme réel là encore
je cite la prévision du gouvernement qui
est le 4,3% ce qui serait moins que la
valeur du PIB qui augmenterait de
6,5%, ce décalage de recettes par
rapport aux PIB accentuées par les
mesures votées de baisse d'impôt je
pense notamment la suppression de la
dernière tranche de la taxe d'habitation
et la première étape de cette CVAE
explique que le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire devrait baisser
points à 44,3% mais c'est encore une
fois toujours du fait la dynamique de
recettes excellent forte il y a pas de
maîtrise spécifique du désendettement en
cause face à cela la dépense publique
progresserait moins vite que l'inflation
du fait je le disais du repli des
dépenses de soutien face à la crise
sanitaire de relance au total le déficit
augmenterait à nouveau à 4,9 points de
PIB d'après 4,7 en 2022 disons que c'est
stable avec une tendance à la hausse le
défi structurel demeurait inchangé à 4
points de PIB la dette atteindrait 109,6
points de PIB c'est un repli plus de
points dont on pourrait se réjouir
davantage s'il n'était exclusivement dû
je dis bien exclusivement à l'effet de
l'inflation sur le dénominateur donc il
y a aucun effort de désendettement qui
est marqué dans
cette situation de finance publique la
conclusion c'est bien ce que je disais
c'est-à-dire que cette vraie est une
année blanche en termes de redressement
de finances publiques
qui a pas grand chose dans l'entendre de
ce point de vue là ça reste un plateau
très élevé tout de même au regard de la
situation dans le reste et puis de la
zone euro qui pour la plupart d'entre
eux sont entrées un peu moins endettés
que nous ou substantiellement dans la
crise covid et qui font un effort un peu
plus marqué et un peu plus rapidement
que nous et donc il y a des effets
divergence qui s'observent
incontestablement dont on doit tenir
compte je viens maintenant à la
trajectoire
2023-2027 tracé par le pestab en
ajoutant ce n'est pas un élément de
réponse tout à fait votre question
monsieur le Président mais c'est déjà
une indication qui les fondamentale que
nous puissions que vous puissiez
disposer d'une loi de programmation à
l'automne
cette trajectoire vient tourner la page
de crise sanitaire le message de la cour
il est simple
c'est cramer le déficitait moins de 3%.
et quand je dis moins de 3% je veux dire
en vérité significativement moins de 3%
de ce point dur les objectifs de
la du pestable sont plus ambitieux que
ceux de la première du premier mouture
du projet de loi de programmation qui
vous a été soumis Elton dernier c'est un
objectif atteignable mais au prix d'un
effort très substantiel sur la dépense
publique d'autant que le scénario
macroéconomique qui sous-tend cet
objectif dans le pestable en tout cas
avec optimiste et donc il est à la merci
d'une déception
je redis ma formule qui devient chez moi
presque à mantra il faut baser notre
trajectoire sur un objectif ambitieux et
2,7 de déficit en 2027 sur messieurs
mais sans plus
baisser la dette des 2027 26 et
ambitieux c'est pas non plus la mer à
boire et des hypothèses crédibles et
réalistes
si vous avez un objectif ambitieux
pas si l'objectif n'est pas ambitieux
vous n'êtes pas à la hauteur de ce qui
est nécessaire donc il faut les deux
c'est assez tôt là qu'il faudra examiner
le projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques et c'est par une loi
de programmation que nous pourrons
réaliser cette équation les crises
sanitaires puis énergétiques ont
propulsé notre public à des niveaux
historiques il faut maintenant retrouver
des marges de manœuvre pour redresser
nos finances publiques c'est le point de
départ la première ministre a annoncé la
semaine dernière aux assises la
Sébastien il y a deux semaines
maintenant aux acides et finances
publiques que le projet de loi de
programmation de finances publiques pour
202327 sera redéposé sur le bureau des
assemblées en septembre je crois dans
une session extraordinaire
c'est absolument impératif je ne cesse
de le redire non seulement regarde nous
a engagements européens mais aussi pour
ancrer pour expliciter pour étayer notre
finance publique et pour l'heure nous
basons sur le pestable ce qui est mieux
que rien mais ce qui n'est pas
juridiquement solide et cette assurément
pour le premier président de la Cour des
comptes pour l'institution que je
préside un sujet ce projet de la loi
devra selon moi apporter des réponses
claires à trois enjeux majeures le
premier je l'ai évoqué celui du risque
de divergence française au sein de la
zone euro puisque la trajectoire
proposée par le pesta mais moins
ambitieuse que celle de nos principaux
pays européens vous avez là devant vous
un graphique qui le monde très
clairement en la matière nous sommes
allez disons-le les moins ambitieux nous
tous et donc cette divergence s'accroît
très
deuxième enjeu c'est le réalisme des
prévisions macroéconiques utilisées pour
construire cette trajectoire de retour
ces trois pour cent j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire quand nous avons
examiné le pestable que les hypothèses
proposées étaient trop optimiste
notamment en termes de croissance
potentielle elles sont au dessus de
toutes les prévisions en la matière
enfin le troisième enjeu c'est celui de
la maîtrise des dépenses avec le niveau
déjà atteint par nos prélèvements
obligatoires évidemment
je ne ferme jamais moi pour ma part le
débat sur l'impôt la peau est un
instrument d'allocation et de
redistribution est utilisable en termes
de niveau tout de même il est compliqué
je pense d'aller beaucoup plus haut et
donc c'est sur la dépense qu'il faudra
nécessairement faire porter l'effort et
les ordres de grandeur sont connus avec
une croissance de la dépense publique en
volume limitée à 0,4.2 PIB par an
hors chars
d'intérêt c'est en réalité la si sur ce
chiffre entre 10 et 12 milliards d'euros
d'économies net qu'il faut réaliser
chaque année ce alors que de nouvelles
dépenses ont été annoncées la
crédibilité et le succès de cette
démarche exige donc que le projet qui
vous sera soumis soit aussi ambitieux et
précis sur les réformes des politiques
publiques qui permettront de réaliser
ces économies
d'où mon quatrième moment la revue de
dépenses à laquelle s'est engagé le
gouvernement et que la Cour propose
d'emblée d'accès sur la qualité et sur
les résultats
je le dis depuis longtemps
ce point de vue là je suis satisfaite
d'avoir été sinon écoutez du moins
entendu une telle revue est
indispensable elle peut être elle doit
être un instrument puissant au service
de l'objectif d'une programmation plus
réelle réussie si elle est menée et
chaque terme compte dans la durée avec
détermination
si elle porte sur un périmètre large
enfin si elle implique et responsabilise
tout le niveau d'administration publique
si vous ne faites pas tout ça à la fois
disons-le quand même c'est pas une revue
de dépenses publiques c'est du Canada
Dry ça peut en avoir le goût mais ça
n'en a pas la saveur tout de même
et j'ajoute une chose c'est qu'une revue
de dépenses publiques n'est pas
seulement et pas d'abord un exercice
budgétaire c'est beaucoup plus ambitieux
exigeant en réalité cela consiste
d'abord à les regarder
la situation des politiques publiques
en faire une véritable revue et une fine
peut-être dans découler les économies
mais c'est l'inverse d'un mécanisme de
rabot c'est beaucoup plus intelligent
c'est beaucoup plus exigeant
un tel exercice n'est pas une nouveauté
pour nos partenaires
les organisations internationales comme
l'OCDE le FMI la Commission européenne
encourage ce type d'exercice en France
il y a eu quatre tentatives passées
n'ont pas tout à fait de cette nature
enfin on les connaît les audits de
modernisation de l'État en 2005 la RGPP
en 2007 la modernisation de l'action
publique la MAP en 2012 et le plan
action publique 2022 en 2017
c'est des marches étaient pour
l'essentiel limitées aux dépenses de
fonctionnement courant de l'état
elles n'ont abouti de ce fait qu'il y a
des résultats très modestes et la
dynamique de la dépense publique que
nous n'avons jamais réussi à infléchir
depuis 50 ans quel que soit l'indicateur
utilisé et le témoin de cela
la nouvelle génération de revues de
dépenses doit en tirer les
conclusions elle doit prendre acte des
insuffisances de ces tentatives et être
considérer l'origine comme l'exercice
beaucoup plus holistique globale
ambitieux
c'est l'occasion pour moi de mettre en
place une gouvernance des finances
publiques qui soit saine et efficace qui
associe toutes les administrations
publiques c'est à dire l'état et ses
opérateurs la sécurité sociale les
collectivités territoriales en portant
les forces sur toutes les dépenses
qu'elles soient de fonctionnement ou
d'investissement et pour tous les
secteurs
toutes les dépenses doivent être
soumises aux exigences similaires de
qualité de soutenabilité et c'est
pourquoi nous avons placé la qualité de
la dépense publique au cœur de notre
contribution à cette revue de dépenses
et nous avons identifié les points
d'amélioration c'est l'objet de ce
chapitre 4 qui je crois assez original
je ne vois pas dans la littérature
publique française en tout cas de choses
comparables ma conviction notre
conviction c'est que là réduction
brutale uniforme de dépenses publiques
n'est pas une solution j'ai déjà dit
maintes fois quand j'ai maintes fois
c'est peut-être depuis 30 ans que
l'austérité était la pire des options et
le rabot la pire des procédures seul une
recherche de qualité déficience doit
être la clé de la maîtrise dépense
publique et de l'amélioration de la
qualité des politiques publiques
pourquoi soulever cette question de la
qualité je fais comme beaucoup et je
pense comme vous dans votre diversité un
constat c'est un paradoxe français de la
dépense
nous avons fait dans notre pays depuis
très longtemps un choix nous avons une
préférence collective pour la dépense au
niveau élevé de porte résultat notre
dépense plus qui a augmenté depuis 2008
de 28% volume et par habitant et ne
cesse de croître la dépense publique
dans le PIB représente 58% du PIB c'est
8 points de plus que la moyenne
européenne c'est considérable je ne
porte aucun jugement de valeur on
pourrait accepter un tel niveau de
dépenses à une condition c'est que la
satisfaction des usagers soit à la
hauteur de la quantité or
on constate depuis le début des années
2000 simultanément cette montée un
déclin de la satisfaction dans les
services publics
si nous pensions tous que notre système
d'éducatif était parfait si nous
constatons que nous augmentions notre
classement dans les
grand pizza si notre politique du
logement permettait des constructions
massives et une politique de logements
social parfaite on pourrait dire
alléluia est-ce que c'est le cas non et
donc les contribuables sont en droit
d'interroger le rapport qualité-prix des
politiques publiques on peut dépenser
beaucoup à condition on dépense très
bien mais si la qualité de la dépense
est approximative alors on crée un
hiatus une contradiction une frustration
et au final une colère nous avons donc
réfléchi à la qualité de la dépense
publique en partant de questions simples
à trois étapes clés conception
déploiement évaluation de la dépense en
premier lieu parlons un instant de la
conception des dispositifs de dépenses
il est aujourd'hui je crois nécessaire
de mieux étayer leur valeur ajoutée au
travers notamment la ciblage plus
pertinent d'assigner à ses dépenses des
objectifs plus clair ou hiérarchisés de
veiller à ce que c'est les dépenses
soient cohérentes non redondantes par
rapport au dis existant en veillant
également plus rigoureusement la
cohérence des initiatives entre les
différents niveaux d'administration
enfin on associe en plus étroitement les
parties prenantes et en vérifiant la
compatibilité climatique dès la
conception de la dépense la mise en
place des études d'impact obligatoire
depuis 2009 n'a pas non plus permis
d'oreiller le digne de dépenses et je
vais donc défendre une idée un peu plus
disruptive qui est la contre-expertise
indépendante systématique des études
d'impact par un organisme issus du monde
académique
deuxième niveau c'est le déploiement des
dispositifs de dépenses les crises
récentes ont montré que notre
administration était capable de dépenser
vite et même bien mais
il faut aller plus loin trouver le bon
équilibre entre rapidité contrôle du
paiement à bon droit et lutte contre la
fraude la Cour estime que la revue de
dépenses doit être intégrer ces deux
dimensions toujours au stade du
déploiement la courbe observe qu'une
fois les crédits votés les systèmes de
répartition des moyens entre service
territoire opérateur par exemple entre
université tribunaux collectivité
territoriale consiste un enjeu majeur il
faut donc pas se contenter d'examiner
une enveloppe globale mais descendre un
peu plus bas d'autant plus que ces
systèmes de répartition font une grande
inertie et vous savez sur vos
territoires que ça crée des inégalités
parce qu'on privilégie les dotations
historiques au détriment d'objectifs
prioritaire enfin je vais être un peu
rude vous avez interroger aussi
là-dessus mais je suis le président le
volet performance
c'est un peu je le crains
l'administration qui conçoit ses propres
indicateurs de performance à destination
des corps de contrôle sous le regard
indifférent des commanditaires
politiques et du grand public la voie
que nous proposons c'est une vaste
ouverture c'est un grand coup d'air il
faut franchir une table audacieuse dans
la matière enfin les gens on termine en
bout de chaîne l'évaluation constitue la
troisième étape du récit de la dépense
est indispensable pour mesurer
l'efficacité la performance et surtout
pour susciter une boucle d'amélioration
continue il faut donc inclure dans le
dispositif juridique des nouveaux
dispositifs de dépenses une clause
d'évaluation systématique et ouverte
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
cette grille d'analyse de la qualité
proposée par la Cour permet nous soyons
pas négatifs de constater heureusement
certains progrès accomplis depuis une
quinzaine d'années notamment avec la
simplification la numérisation mais
aussi
de nombreuses voix d'amélioration et je
le redis si elle porte sur l'ensemble
des dépenses sans rien exclure a priori
si elle responsabilité toutes les
administrations si elle s'inscrit dans
la durée s'il reste sous tendu par une
volonté politique forte alors la revue
de dépenses pourrait être le vieux de
l'amélioration de la qualité de la
dépense plus que ça soustabilité
à défaut nous produirons un exercice
utile sur le plan financier mais qui ne
traitera pas les problèmes à la racine
qui ne permettra pas d'améliorer les
politiques publiques la satisfaction à
l'égard du service public et surtout qui
fera que nous serons les uns les autres
et vous d'abord confrontez chaque année
un exercice budgétaire assez brutal
assez frustre et finalement totalement
frustrant difficile
insatisfaisant et à mon avis incapable
de produire des résultats à la hauteur
voilà il faut passer à l'action et c'est
pourquoi la cour est plus que jamais à
votre disposition je le redis ça lui
pour aller gustatif pour exécutif aussi
des citoyens
pour mettre à profit sa propre
connaissance des politiques publiques et
donc je République demain des notes
thématiques dans 9 domaines d'action
prioritaires les dépenses fiscales les
aides aux entreprises en temps de crise
la transition écologique l'éducation les
forces de sécurité intérieure les
relations financières la formation
professionnelle le logement et les soins
de ville merci de votre attention et je
maintiens à votre disposition avec ceux
qui m'entourent pour répondre si je le
peux à vos questions vous avez
préoccupations
merci monsieur le Premier Président et
donc pour aller dans votre sens je vais
demander un rapporteur général de réagir
à vos propos merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Président et votre
brillante équipe je l'appellerai presque
la dream team de la cour alors comme
c'est c'est pas très français je vais
l'appeler la belle équipe
j'ai compris je partage qu'on peut pas
dire alléluia
de la même manière vous nous avez
apporté le
kit complet du prêt à bien et mieux
dépenser
on va regarder on va essayer d'en faire
bon usage et de s'en inspirer et enfin
vous avez appelé à ce qu'il y a un appel
d'air
ce que j'appellerais moi bousculer les
habitudes et les conservatistes alors
figurez-vous que pour nous ici ça tombe
bien c'est exactement ce à quoi on
s'était
virtué notamment lors du dernier projet
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques et on a reçu une fin de
non-recevoir plus ou moins aimable de la
part du gouvernement
j'entends qu'il consulte autour de
nouvelles assises mais ça échaudé craint
l'eau froide puisque globalement
tout ce qui a été proposé à l'époque par
le Sénat alors nous avait appris que on
allait rentrer dans des temps d'une
rigueur affreuse on a entendu parler de
beaucoup de brutalité moi j'ai plutôt
appris dans la vie publique que tout ce
qu'on ne fait pas aujourd'hui
et plus douloureux quand on veut s'y
atteler un peu plus tard et vous l'avez
dit les compteurs sont tous à peu près
au rouge
et donc plus il y a une dérive de nos
comptes publics plus l'effort que nous
allons devoir
réaliser sera difficile à mettre en
oeuvre et peut-être à accepter par nos
concitoyens puisque comparativement à
nos concurrents si on prenait je sais
pas on va dire un marathon on part on va
on va plutôt partir en queue et plutôt
un peu lesté par ces résultats
néanmoins
je souscris évidemment aux propos et je
pense qu'on peut je peux le faire sans
sans grand risque au nom également des
travaux de notre commission pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées mais je pense
que c'est je le dis le c'est une c'est
d'abord à regret et c'est pour moi une
source de préoccupation bord
d'inquiétude parce que la situation ne
s'est effectivement pas améliorée pour
des raisons exogènes entendables mais ça
n'empêche
pas non plus même dans ces temps
d'essayer de bien tenir la dépense et
puis comme il nous a pas échappé que en
plus à côté de ces problèmes strictement
budgétaires nous avons aussi des
problèmes
comment dirais-je de cohésion sociale et
de dégradation du climat
globalement global du climat social en
France c'est finalement assez difficile
vous voyez une agence de notation avait
un peu alerté
sur ce sujet ça avait été pris de haut
que soit une agence de notation que soit
des politiques soient le monde
économique ou les Français il y a
finalement une préoccupation générale à
laquelle on va devoir répondre
voilà de les éléments que je voulais
donner et pour ne pas être long je veux
juste
me permettre de vous interroger sur deux
sujets le premier vous l'avez évoqué
d'ailleurs dans votre propos notamment
dans la partie introductive
à certains membres de loi de
programmation qui en général d'ailleurs
dans les assemblées obtiennent des
accords très larges qui est logiquement
permettent ensuite d'espérer voir la
mise en œuvre
être plus aisé dans les dans la
programmation budgétaire mais il y a
quand même une difficulté c'est que ces
nouvelles lois de programmation n'avait
pas été intégré dans le projet de la
programmation des finances publiques
donc on se retrouve en porte-à-faux
quel est votre appréciation sur notre
capacité à tenir tout de même la
trajectoire à laquelle vous nous appelez
et que nous partageons et puis un
deuxième sujet qui est un sujet
auquel le Sénat
est attentif depuis un certain temps
c'est le sujet finalement des des
opérateurs quel qu'il soit puisque
aujourd'hui il y en a près de 500 c'est
plus de 76 milliards d'euros de
subventions c'est 400 000 emplois mais
en fait on s'aperçoit que ces opérateurs
sont en charge de service public mais
également de modalités de financement et
donc d'une certaine manière ils
échappent à une bonne maîtrise de nos
comptes publics
quelle est la vie que porte la cour sur
ce que j'appellerai moins un peu ce
dévoiement de la dépense publique qui
rend plus complexe peut-être la maîtrise
à laquelle nous aspirons je le crois
tous selon des modalités qui peuvent
varier
merci Monsieur la potagerale si vous
souhaitez répondre je vais aussi
répondre à votre question initiale
monsieur le Président on m'a demandé
quelques exemples d'aides non ciblées ou
mal ciblés vous trouverez dans les 9
notes publiées demain beaucoup
d'exemples même si encore une fois c'est
pas un travail à finalité budgétaire
mais beaucoup plus la finalité de
réflexion sur les politiques publiques
mais je vais en prendre ici deux par
exemple les aides à la rénovation
énergétique par exemple ma prime rénove
sur laquelle la Cour a publié en 2021
nous dit flash
les gains en consommation énergétique ne
sont pas mesurées
une conditionne pas l'aide ça ne remet
pas du tout en cause d'ailleurs la
pertinence d'aider à l'adaptation des
logements aux réchauffement climatique
c'est une priorité pour les Français il
faut le faire le dispositif en soi est
utile mais il y a un problème là de
ciblage très clairement puisque c'était
la question que vous posez je peux aussi
citer d'ailleurs le chèque énergie avec
une distribution trop large probablement
disons qu'il a sans doute d'abord servi
à soutenir le pouvoir d'achat plutôt
qu'à être orienté sur sa finalité
initiale et puis jamais 203 peut-être
les soutiens l'apprentissage
une aide exceptionnelle à l'embauche
d'apprenti qui a été mise en place
pendant la crise sanitaire dont on peut
se féliciter d'ailleurs puisque
l'apprentissage se considérablement
relancé mais ce qu'on constate ça vous
le verrez demain dans une des notes
c'est que ça plutôt favoriser les
diplômés dans l'insertion sur le marché
du travail
alors que c'est de la station est
pourtant plus facile pour eux et donc le
nombre d'apprentis a vraiment explosé de
35000 en 2017 à 837 milliards 2022 on
pourrait se féliciter davantage du
chiffre
si il y avait peut-être pas dans cette
population certains qu'il en avait pas
forcément besoin et si on n'est pas
d'autres qui en ont un grand besoin et
qui est tenu de côté on voit en effet
vous avez parlé sur le rapporteur
général de problèmes sociaux dans notre
pays c'est pas la peine de faire un
dessin aux cellules des territoires que
vous êtes tout ceci n'est pas
complètement sans rapport sur les deux
questions que vous avez posé monsieur le
rapporteur général vous savez que je
vous conseille les finances publiques
est désormais que je préside également
saisi sur les lois de programmation
sectorielles et vous avez été déjà
vous-même
amener à débattre sur trois de ces lois
la locmi la loi de programmation sur la
justice et puis maintenant la loi de
programmation militaire ça représente
quelques 20% du nouveau périmètre de
dépenses de l'État
et
j'ai pas de commentaires à faire sur le
fond bien sûr c'est pas du tout dans ma
compétence ce que je constate c'est
qu'il y a tout de même 20 % des dépenses
donc de l'État qui ont été en quelque
sorte sanctuarisés que ces trois lois
manifestent des priorités politiques
publiques et donc sont plutôt
dépensières ou expansives disons si on
ne veut pas avoir de connotation sur ce
mot là
ça signifie que quand on veut
limiter la dépense plus qu'à 0,4 point
volume et vous avez 20 % du périmètre de
l'État qui lui est en expansion c'est le
reste qui doit supporter l'effort et que
l'effort en réalité surtout le reste
doit être plus important que ce 04 en
volume et c'est à partir de ça notamment
que nous déduisons ces chiffres de 10 à
12 milliards plutôt 12 que 10 en réalité
tu économie annuelle 50 à 60 milliards
sur la période de la trajectoire
d'où en effet une nécessité renforcée ce
que vous soulignez d'avoir une loi de
programmation d'ensemble qui dessine une
cohérence et qui disent aussi secteur
par secteur où sont les réformes qui
permettront de parvenir un objectif de
maîtrise de dépense qui tiennent un peu
la route sur les opérateurs en effet ils
sont 438 en 2023 il reçoivent 76,6
milliards de subventions
la Cour a déjà rappelé le besoin de
renforcer leur tutelle notamment avec
des contrats d'objectifs et de moyens
mais seulement 22% ont un tel contrat
alors je dirais pas qu'ils sont en soi
indépoiement mais ce qui est
problématique c'est l'absence de
contrôle sur leur activité le
gouvernement avait promis de le faire
mais je dois dire que depuis 2022 il y a
quatre qui ont pris forme c'est quand
même très très peu donc ça me donne
l'occasion de rappeler ce message devant
vous et d'ajouter
en revenant sur ce que je disais sur les
revues de dépenses que les opérateurs de
l'État ne doivent pas échapper à la
revue que la revue de dépenses encore
une fois ne fait sens que si elle est
vraiment holistique c'est-à-dire si elle
touche
à la fois l'état et ses opérateurs la
sécurité sociale les collectivités
territoriales les dépenses
investissements les dépenses de
fonctionnement sinon encore une fois
nous sommes en deçà l'exigence d'un tel
exercice je sais qu'il est très
compliqué je le crois pourtant
indispensable parce que il faut m'en
sortir de cette espèce de spirale
annuelle de débat budgétaire
nécessaire ce n'était le premier
protagonistes mais qui n'ont pas
forcément la granularité ou la finesse
indispensable si on veut à la fois
réduire fortement la dépense mais le
faire avec des politiques publiques qui
fonctionnent mieux c'est ça l'objectif
que nous devons collectivement
poursuivre
et merci pour la dream team
merci monsieur le Premier Président
alors en tant que sénateur je mets dans
la discussion en général je vous poserai
moi une question sur
sur la méthode que vous préconisez que
nous connaissons
cette méthode d'analyse globale des
politiques publiques permettant ensuite
de travailler sur le budget ça paraît de
bon sens
beaucoup d'élus locaux
la pratique ou l'ombre pratiquait un
moment de leur vie locale généralement
quand on arrive comme nouveau maire par
exemple
on remet à plat l'ensemble des
politiques on regarde là où on peut
économiser là où on peut financer de
nouvelles politiques que l'on souhaite
mener donc globalement j'allais dire
c'est un exercice que nous connaissons
mais pour l'avoir à pratiquer moi une
fois je me souviens très bien dans ma
ville rien que dans ma ville est sur les
politiques publiques d'une petite ville
30 000 habitants il m'avait fallu plus
d'un an pour le faire dans les
conditions que vous indiquez c'est à
dire dans des conditions où on est aussi
à l'écoute des services à l'écoute de la
population et essayer de déboucher sur
quelque chose de construit en commun
plus d'un an
et je voulais vous interroger sur la
durée que vous imaginez pour la
politique que vous nous proposez et son
lien finalement même s'il faut sans
doute le mener son lien avec les
économies nécessaires à court terme
finalement
qui sont
nécessaires pour améliorer selon votre
position évidemment le déficit public
voilà là j'ai un peu de mal parce que
c'est un système extrêmement lourd
holistique vous l'avez dit c'est un joli
mot mais concrètement c'est un système
extrêmement lourd à mettre en place pour
des politiques publiques et donc
j'aimerais aussi vous entendre
sur d'après vous
quelle est la durée de ce processus par
rapport à l'enjeu que vous proposez
Vincent Delahaye puis Sylvie vermillier
merci à Monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président de la Cour des
comptes pour cette analyse qu'on ne peut
que partager puis pour les éléments de
méthode que vous avez avancé que je
partage totalement sauf que
effectivement dans la réalité on sent
pas vraiment une détermination très
forte en la matière vous avez dit qu'il
fallait de la détermination on sent pas
une volonté d'embrasser effectivement
toutes les toutes les dépenses dans tous
les domaines quand on voit la revue de
dépenses qui a été annoncée en fait elle
est très limitée et puis
l'installation dans la durée moi je suis
très dubitatif alors je partage sur la
méthode je pense qu'il serait
intéressant comme d'avoir des études
d'impact beaucoup mieux
beaucoup mieux rempli et surtout avec un
impact sur la dépense publique à chaque
fois des
nouvelles lois que nous propose de voter
et je pense qu'une analyse de la cour
là-dessus serait peut-être intéressant
de quand même de regarder un peu les
études d'impact ce qui est ce qu'elle
contenait à l'origine et en réalité ce
qu'il y a eu par la suite parce que
effectivement il faut qu'a priori on est
des études d'impact sérieuse et solide
et qu'ensuite on a une évaluation solide
malheureusement on anime ni l'autre donc
c'est quand même assez embêtant pour ma
part je effectivement je suis un peu
dubitatif sur la mise en oeuvre de tout
cela j'aimerais bien que qu'il y ait un
petit peu plus de bonté alors après
j'ai deux questions la première page 4
vous avez un graphique très intéressant
sur la dépense publique l'évolution de
la dépense publique depuis 2010 à 2022
et on voit que la moyenne alors c'est en
pourcentage du PIB j'aurais bien aimé
aussi avoir les milliards en face mais
on voit que
2020-2021-2022 on reste très nettement
au-dessus de la moyenne sans baisse et
page 19 10 pardon sur le déficit vous
mettez que les mesures ponctuelles et
temporaires ne représentent en 2021-2022
et 2023 que 0,1% du déficit je suis un
peu surpris parce que on reste très
nettement au dessus au niveau des penses
il y a pour moi une incohérence entre le
graphique de la page 4 et le les
informations qui sont données page 10 et
en plus page 10 vous dites que le seul
structurel a baissé de 5 à 4 points
entre 2021 et 2022 je sais pas à quoi
c'est dû être baisse d'un point de ce
sol structurel je suis un petit peu
surpris et ma deuxième question c'est
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il serait
possible en France d'avoir la même
pratique qu'en Allemagne
c'est à dire que les Allemands prévoient
pour 2024 une baisse de 6% de la dépense
dans tous les domaines sauf la défense
et une baisse de leur déficit de 2,5
points de PIB
donc est-ce qu'on pourrait être un
moment donné aussi rigoureux que les
Allemands
[Musique]
et éventuellement les supprimer merci
merci Sylvie Bernard delcro puisse
Pascal Savoldelli merci merci monsieur
le Président pour
pour ces constats et analyse
du coup moi j'aurais deux ou trois
questions
est-ce que cela vous paraît on est
d'accord évidemment sur le constat et
sur l'objectif vous dites le 2,7% allez
à l'échéance 2027 par atteignable
pensez-vous que on peut atteindre cet
objectif avec le seul levier des
dépenses publiques tout en répondant
est-ce compatible avec les besoins
malgré tout nouveau de dépenses et on
pense notamment à tous les toutes les
dépenses liées à la transition
énergétique et écologique
vous avez évoqué la question des crédits
qui sont déjà engagés engagés dans les
lois de programmation 20% vous l'avez
rappelé du coup pour être sûr d'avoir
bien compris quand vous évoquez un
besoin d'économie net de 10 à 12
milliards d'euros par an est-ce que vous
tenez compte des crédits qui sont
engagés qui sont votés dans les
différentes lois de de programmation
et puis dernier point vous évoquez à la
page 16 la nécessité que les
collectivités territoriales prennent
aussi leur part à cet effort de
réduction des dépenses publiques vous
pouvez nous dire nous en dire un peu
plus sur ce sujet Comment avec quel avec
elle méthode et puis dernière
observation quand on compare la France
aux autres pays de l'Union européenne
évidemment on
sait quand même que notamment sur les
dépenses militaires et je pense à votre
programmation militaire les dépenses
militaires sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes dans tous les pays de l'Union
européenne donc il faudrait aussi
peut-être comment dire ça pondéré
pondéré en fonction de ses dépenses là
je vous remercie merci Bernard Pascal ça
vole des lits puis Christine Labarde
oui merci monsieur le Président de la
Cour des comptes pour vos analyses
d'ailleurs que nous utilisons dans dans
nos expressions politiques pas forcément
en arrivant tous ici dans les mêmes
conclusions mais il faut respecter et
prendre en compte le trail qui nous est
présenté d'abord une question technique
si elle sert à tout le monde ça sera
bien
je sais pas la différence entre
l'inflation sous-jacente et l'inflation
totale ça c'est une question technique
mais ça me permettra d'apprendre encore
des choses ce matin après page 16 vous
évoquez dans la nécessité de revues des
dépenses au champ large responsabilisant
tous les acteurs vous évoquez les
collectivités territoriales
donc il serait quand même bien que ça
soit un peu plus précisé c'est un champ
qui mérite des recommandations assez
précises donc quelles sont celles de la
Cour des comptes et ma troisième
question je sais pas si
ce qui évoqué mon collègue précédemment
mais je vois pas 17 la singularité
française en matière de dépense publique
entre 2000 et 2022
moi je pense qu'il serait vraiment utile
que la Cour des comptes nous fasse une
étude d'impact
parce que vers quelle destination va
l'augmentation du volume de nos dépenses
publiques
vous avez évoqué monsieur le Président
des critères d'efficacité déficience
moi à mon sens le premier destinataire
de nos politiques publiques c'est
l'usager c'est le citoyen
donc il sera intéressant de voir vers où
va la dépense publique ou les dépenses
publiques donc acquis aux usagers vous
en avez parlé donc quelle évolution du
droit commun par rapport à l'évolution
des dépenses publiques ça je pense que
ça soulève un intérêt général de tout le
monde ici la dépense publique va au
droit commun et après nous dire aussi un
distinguons comment la dépense publique
va aux entreprises et au marché
financiers vous voyez pour qu'on ait des
éléments de clarté merci
Pascal Christine lavard depuis Didier
Rambaud
merci monsieur le Président et merci à
Monsieur le Premier Président pour ce
pour ce rapport alors ma première
question porte sur le vote
récent lundi en fait par le Sénat du
rejet de la loi de réglement 2022 et a
confirmé le rejet de la loi de règlement
2021 donc quelle conséquence cela
va-t-il avoir sur les prochains projets
de loi de finances
si en a-t-il
et ma seconde question porte sur la
partie de l'évaluation donc je partage
complètement tout ce que vous écrivez
mais ne faudrait-il pas d'ailleurs
envisagé dans la prochaine loi de
programmation des finances publiques
d'inscrire dans le dur que les études
d'impact dont tout le monde ici est
d'accord pour dire qu'elles sont très
perfectibles
imposer en fait au stade de l'étude
d'impact d'inscrire les outils de mesure
les variables à collecter et à regarder
pour permettre ensuite l'évaluation
merci Christine Didier Rambaud puis
Christian Billac merci monsieur le
Président deux questions la première là
déjà été partiellement abordé mais je la
répète ça concerne le rôle des lois de
programmation sectorielle comment
peut-on maîtriser des dépenses publiques
à partir du moment où on est lié par des
lois de programmation et puis bon on
sait qu'aujourd'hui tout mis tout
ministre rêve d'avoir et puis porté par
les acteurs locaux qui sont derrière lui
rêvent d'avoir sa loi de programmation
deuxième question c'est dont vous
appelez la nécessité de revoir les les
dépenses toute la dépense publique et
puis parmi celles-ci moi j'assistera un
secteur qui est au Sénat et sur lequel
nous sommes très chatouilleux c'est
celui des collectivités territoriales
est-ce qu'on peut considérer les
collectivités territoriales au même rang
que la sécurité sociale est l'état à
partir du moment où elle elles ont quand
même obligation de voter leur budget en
équilibre elles ont l'impression quand
même d'avoir ces dernières années
beaucoup de données beaucoup plus donnés
pour maîtriser la dépense publique que
l'État ou la sécurité sociale je
rappelle qu'entre 2010 quand même et
2017 14 milliards d'euros qui ont été
amputés sur les dotations globales de de
fonctionnement voilà la remarque voilà
un zoom particulier sur les sur les
collectivités territoriales merci merci
Didier Christian BIAC puis Isabelle
briquet
merci monsieur le Président et merci à
Monsieur le Premier Président de la Cour
des comptes pour ce rapport on ne peut
qu'être d'accord
moi je me demandais j'y serai pas bon en
ce pays où on adore tout comme mémorer
de profiter de la fin de l'année pour
commémorer les 40 ans de centralisations
et les 50 ans de budget en déficit
auprès de la gueule 50 ans de déficit
quand même
ça mériterait d'être salué
moi je crois que si on faisait ça on
s'apercevrait du millefeuille
qu'il faut absolument combattre alors
pas le millefeuille en tant que telle
mais vous savez le millefeuille à la
pâte et à la crème et à chaque couche de
pâte et une couche de crème
lorsqu'on a
le sport le ministre des Sports la patte
chez le sportif et la crème c'est
l'administration
dans le ministère la région la pâte et
la crème le département la pâte et la
crème l'intercourt la pâte et la crème
et la commune quand même ne peuvent pas
rester à l'écart donc à nouveau la pâte
et la crème donc moi je crois que si on
arrivait à supprimer 50% de la crème ça
serait pas mal malheureusement on ne
prend pas le chemin parce qu'il y a 10
ans un autre exemple on avait les roues
de la chômage et les routes
départementales
alors moi je me disais ça serait bien
que toutes les routes soient
départementales
autour des routes nationales mais
Kennedy aujourd'hui on a les routes
nationales les routes régionales les
routes départementales et les routes
métropolitaines et un pot de crème de
plus on est le champion on est le
champion alors monsieur le Président moi
j'aurai une première question c'est à la
page 16 vous dites qu'il faut que tout
le monde participe je mets un petit
bémol sur les collectivités mais le
réalisme dit qu'il faudra aussi que les
collectivités participent mais justement
par la méthode de suppression de la
crème et pas sur les services aux
usagers mais après il y a une question
que je voudrais vous poser
c'est en ce qui concerne les opérateurs
parler de la question de la
participation de l'usager
et là moi je me demande si l'usager ou
le contribuable comme on veut il est
capable de distinguer une dépense
obligatoire d'une dépense obligée un
prélèvement obligatoire le prélèvement
obligé parce que je prends l'exemple de
la mutuelle c'est pas un prélèvement
obligatoire le mutuelle santé
mais si c'est pas obligatoire c'est
obligé voilà
et puis on a quand même une évaluation
des résultats de la qualité de la
dépense et je crois que là on a la DG
FIP qui a des logiciels qu'elle peut
dépasser et évolue la dépense mais pas
les recettes induites donc pas la
définition de la dépense et je crois que
là il faudrait aller au fond des choses
et moi je pose une question encore et je
m'arrêterai là est-ce que la Cour
envisage de faire une rapport sur les
niches fiscales
merci Christian Isabelle briquet puis
Stéphane Sautarel
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président tout d'abord merci
pour la pertinence des analyses comme
toujours et de ce rapport qui nous
éclaire dans nos réflexions jeux pour ma
part je vous rejoins quand on vous dites
que l'austérité et la pire des options
et que la logique du rabot n'est pas une
bonne méthode nous en avons la preuve
avec l'application de cette logique au
sein de l'administration territoriale de
l'État depuis des années où l'on voit
aujourd'hui la nécessité d'un réarmement
des services de l'État pour tout d'abord
assurer la préservation des compétences
qui au fil du temps m'a
diminue dangereusement et assuré aussi
garantir un minimum de services publics
à nos concitoyens
[Musique]
merci Isabelle Stéphane Sautarel puis
Gérard Longuet
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Premier Président pour ces
présentations qui viennent confirmer
effectivement la dégradation de nos
comptes en 2022 et l'absence d'évolution
en 2023
donc pour rester sur les sur les
perspectives et la nécessité en fait
d'une méthodologie que vous nous
proposez pour rendre à la fois la
dépense plus efficace de qualité et
peut-être moins récurrente parce que je
pense qu'une de nos difficultés c'est
que lorsque nous amorçons une politique
publique nous avons beaucoup de
difficultés à l'interop pour lorsque
nous voulons décider de nouvelles
priorités moi je regrette que vous ne
fassiez pas partager les fiches qui qui
que vous avez évoquées vont découvrir
demain et en particulier celle qui
concerne la dépense fiscale parce que
au-delà effectivement d'un rapport sur
les sur les niches fiscales je pour ma
part convaincu que à côté des agences à
côté effectivement de l'efficacité de la
dépense à côté de la méthode que vous
proposez de revues de dépenses publiques
qui nécessitera courage et fort partagé
le sujet de la dépense fiscale et
sociale d'ailleurs sont sans doute des
gisements majeurs et sur lesquels on
pourrait avoir de nouvelles
méthodologies en inscrivant des projets
limités bornés dans le temps alors
qu'aujourd'hui je crois qu'une de nos
difficultés c'est cette difficulté
justement
à sortir d'une d'une récurrence qui qui
pose qui pose des difficultés donc je
voulais vous interroger sur ce point
particulier si vous vous pouviez nous
donner quelques pistes qui pourraient
être présentées sur la dépense fiscale
de façon à ce qu'on puisse
éventuellement travailler sur cette
question là pour voir comment prolonger
cette cette question parce que je sais
bien que selon une formule célèbre
derrière chaque niche il y a un chien
mais mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
commence à s'occuper de ce sujet là de
manière plus sérieuse merci beaucoup
merci Stéphane Gérard Longuet puis
Michel cannelle oui merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Premier
Président pour votre rapport page 18
vous envisagez une stratégie pour en
faveur de la bonne dépense la question
que je vous pose est très simple comment
imaginez-vous une stratégie d'alliée
pour poursuivre ce projet qui n'est
défendu dans notre pays absolument par
personne et pour des raisons d'ailleurs
parfaitement évidentes que vous donnez
dans vos trois orientations assumées
faut-il une gouvernance budgétaire plus
moderne dans l'usage de la donnée c'est
à dire mieux connaître notre service
public nous découvrons à cette occasion
que les services publics dont nous
venions encore il y a quelques années
sont tous profondément dégradés je parle
de l'enseignement parce que c'est celui
que je rapporte depuis 10 ans dans cette
commission des enseignants mal payés et
des résultats médiocres ensuite vous
merci Gérard Michel canvet depuis
philippe Dominati merci monsieur le
Président je vais moi aussi remercier le
premier président de la cour pour sa
présentation luminaire et puis les
membres de la Cour pour les 172 pages du
rapport qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui alors comme plusieurs de mes
collègues j'ai lu dans le rapport qu'il
était souhaitait maîtrise de la dépense
devant impliquer davantage les
collectivités territoriales c'est écrit
à la plage 110 et comme eux j'ai plutôt
le sentiment que les ressources des
collectivités territoriales ont été
contingentées ces dernières années
notamment les dotations en même temps
que le pouvoir de recourir à l'impôt a
été diminué puisque une partie de des
taxes ont été supprimés c'est dire que
les recettes des collectivités ont
plutôt été réduites alors même que les
dépenses continuent de croître et lundi
prochain nous aurons encore la création
du service public de la petite enfance
qui va certainement générer dépenses
supplémentaires parce qu'on sait que les
crèches ça coûte très cher en même temps
que les établissements pour accueillir
les personnes en situation de handicap
où les personnes âgées coûtent aussi
très très cher aux collectivités
territoriales on voit que les dépenses
ont cru de façon abordées donc je
voulais demander
à la Cour comment
aller encore plus loin alors même que
les collectivités territoriales
doivent équilibrer leurs comptes et le
font effectivement et puis à la page 21
de la présentation que vous avez
effectuée monsieur le Premier Président
vous avez évoqué l'existence d'une
évaluation importante indépendante de la
dépense effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui est absolument nécessaire je
voulais vous demander comment vous
entendiez concevoir cette évaluation
indépendante vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure
l'importance de l'évaluation académique
à laquelle recourt les Allemands et à
laquelle nous pourrions nous aussi
recourir mais la Cour des comptes
n'est-elle finalement une forme de
d'évaluation indépendante cela
voudrait-il dire que la Cour ne réalise
pas la mission qui serait la sienne
est-ce que c'est cela comme ça aussi
qu'on pourrait lire ce qui a été écrit
ici et en tant que rapporteur spécial de
la mission aide publique au
développement nous avons voté par la loi
du 4 août 2021 la création d'une
commission indépendante pour
l'évaluation des politiques publiques de
l'aide au développement de la France
confiée à la Cour des comptes il faut
savoir si cette commission a été mise en
place et si elle fonctionne deux ans
après
merci Michel philippe Dominati merci
monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président je partage comme
tous mes collègues les propos que vous
avez tenus
chez les suivis avec beaucoup d'intérêt
j'ai entendu la question du rapporteur
général et en réalité année après année
le Parlement les commissions des
finances de l'assemblées la Cour des
comptes on a le sentiment d'une certaine
redondance et cette redondance ou
caractérise peut-être par une certaine
impuissance pour maîtriser la dépense
publique il y a une dizaine d'années
vous vous en souvenez il y avait ce
débat sur la règle d'or que l'on devait
éventuellement inscrire dans la
Constitution vous avez fait partie d'un
gouvernement ou finalement on est passé
dans la loi organique le débat a eu lieu
et puis ça passait de mode on en parle
absolument plus je voulais savoir votre
sentiment sera peut-être cette
occasion loupée à l'époque de savoir si
on devait l'inscrire dans la
Constitution ou pas est-ce que ça aurait
changé quelque chose ou absolument rien
est-ce que c'était
un signe vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
sur le plan pédagogique en réalité on ne
parle absolument pas aujourd'hui
alors lorsqu'on constat de la
dégradation de nos finances publiques
cette préoccupation que nous avions il y
a une dizaine d'années
merci Philippe je ne vois pas d'autres
demandes d'intervention donc monsieur le
Premier Président vous avez la parole
merci pour toutes ces questions qui
comme toujours dans votre assemblée sont
précises
et profondes je vais commencer peut-être
par grouper la réponse que je souhaitais
faire Claude rénal avec une question de
Monsieur le Ministre Longuet celle de
philippe Dominati qui ont terminé parce
qu'il y a une question de méthode
finalement importante
la Cour des comptes
dans ma conception mais je pense que tel
est assez saine
est à sa place c'est-à-dire que c'est
une institution de la République qui est
inscrite dans la Constitution qui a une
vocation d'informations du citoyen qui
se trouve à équidistance entre le
gouvernement et le Parlement
qui est donc puisqu'on raisonne en
termes d'allier le vôtre j'ai prononcé
ce mot dans la pollution je le redis
maintenant en quelque sorte
pour répondre à l'appel de Gérard
Longuet mais je ne crois pas au
gouvernement des juges et je ne crois
pas que des experts autrement dit nous
ne sommes pas les décideurs les
décisions publiques dans ce pays se
prennent par d'autres institutions
l'exécutif et législatif
mais nous sommes là pour informer pour
étayer le débat pour produire de ce
devises objective chiffrées qui ensuite
vous permettent de prendre des décisions
plus éclairées pourquoi est-ce que je
commence par là pour dire qu'on est fait
oui c'est vrai que nous disons souvent
les mêmes choses
mais je n'ai pas pour autant
l'impression que ce soit de
l'impuissance c'est simplement répéter
des messages utiles et nécessaires qu'il
faudra bien entendre avant qu'il
s'impose par eux-mêmes je ne voudrais
pas que notre pays se trouve à un moment
donné devant une situation financière
qui contraignent à agir d'urgence dans
les pires conditions et donc il faut
anticiper et donc je le répète je répète
et d'ailleurs nous essayons aussi de
varier les plaisirs j'insiste notamment
sur ce chapitre 4 sur les revues de
dépenses qui je crois tout à fait
novateur et qui est sans précédentes
dont la littérature je pense
administrative et même assez académique
sur ce sujet là
alors après
comment avancer c'est ça la question je
vais pas revenir sur 2012 et la règle
d'or c'est un autre débat et je faisais
un autre métier j'étais plutôt des
vôtres un homme politique et je ne suis
plus comme premier Président je suis
attaché
l'indépendance et la partialité qui est
sur de ma fonction mais chez les
souvenirs quand même c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque on avait plutôt écarté l'idée
d'une règle d'or quand une situation de
finance publique qui était déjà pas
extraordinaire il y avait la crise
financière quand je suis venu viser
finance en 2012 les déficitations tout
de suite 5% la croissance était à zéro
et une règle d'or
n'aurait pas forcément été efficace elle
aurait eu un effet pour le coup
austéritaire tellement fort que la
croissance déjà nulle aurait été
dégradée donc effectivement à l'époque
nous avions préféré et c'est ce qui m'a
amené devant vous déjà à l'époque
créer le Conseil des finances publiques
et modifier la loi organique sur la loi
de finances publiques des mécanismes de
régulation quelque sorte si j'ai un
regret
c'est une administration à l'époque
c'est que le Conseil finance publique
est à mon sens doté d'un mandat trop
étroit et de moyens trop limité pour
être ce que les Anglo-Saxons appel à
watch dogs chien de garde assez puissant
en la matière je crois qu'il faudra
aller vers son renforcement et quand
nous serons saisis d'une modification de
la gouvernance des finances publiques
européennes sera forcément des contenus
des conséquences sur la loi organique et
sur le rôle des institutions budgétaires
indépendantes puisque l'appropriation
nationale sera plus forte il faut aussi
que le contrôle national soit plus fort
enfin j'anticipe un peu
cette parenthèse est en fait je reviens
à la question de Claude rénale
la revue de dépenses ou en effet
permanente et débouchés effectivement
sur des décisions dans certains pays
comme au Canada c'est vraiment intégré
dans les politiques publiques dès leur
conception à travers les études d'impact
sur lequel plusieurs d'entre nous notre
voulons poser des questions et il faut
élargir le périmètre là aussi plusieurs
vous me posez des questions
ça prend sans doute du temps monsieur le
Président a concevoir et à mettre en
œuvre pas tant que ça parce que
peut-être avons-nous au niveau de l'état
des ressources pour cela un peu plus
importantes qu'à l'échelle une
collective nous ne partons pas de rien
il y a tout même les administrations
publiques l'administration des finances
les inspections générales la Cour des
comptes donc les organismes académiques
nombreux donc je pense qu'ils ont ça
prend sans doute quelques mois mais
encore une fois la finalité n'est pas
budgétaire il s'agit pas de faire
quelque chose pour préparer le PLF 2024
c'est pas mon sujet en revanche il faut
installer au delà de ça avec une volonté
politique quelque chose qui soit plus
réelle donc durable et qui associe tous
les acteurs et j'en profite ici pour
répondre au passage une question que
plusieurs d'entre vous ont soulevé sur
les collectivités territoriales nous ne
faisons pas nous de propositions
d'économies nous ont un constat qui doit
discuté par les associations intelligent
que la situation est finances publiques
des finances publiques de certaines
collectivités et plutôt plus avantageuse
que celle de l'État
et nous disons que la revue de dépenses
publiques doit concerner tout le monde
autrement dit nous ne préconisons pas de
faire l'effort ici ou là mais nous
disons que personne ne doit être à
l'écart de la démarche de revue si elle
se mette en place et derrière ça
monsieur le ministre on arrive à votre
question qui est absolument fondamentale
je sais bien qu'on démarre sans allier
dans cette affaire mais c'est une
révolution culturelle indispensable si
nous ne faisons pas ça à un moment donné
nous serons rattrapés par la patrouille
oui la France n'a pas été dégradée par
une agent de natation est-ce que c'est
pour toujours j'espère que oui mais ce
sera le cas pour toujours si notre
situation de finance publique s'améliore
vraiment et pour qu'elle s'améliore
vraiment il faut on le sait qu'il est
mesures structurelles qui soient prises
j'ajoute et je le redis pardon de me
répéter que si nous ne faisons pas un
exercice de cette nature nous ne
changeons pas de braquet si nous restons
avec une logique très dépensière sans
examiner de trop près comment dire
politique qui soit le gouvernement ou le
Parlement comment on fait on va empiler
dépenses sur les dépenses et après année
empiler des mesures budgétaires un peu
en catastrophe un peu bricolé ce sera
soit du rabot soit du ciblage
enfin pas grand chose d'intelligent et
ce sera de plus en plus douloureux parce
que faire 10 milliards par an purement
budgétaire dans l'exercice budgétaire
lui-même
bon courage bon courage au gouvernement
bon courage au Parlement là-dessus et
une fine et arrivé à créer une
satisfaction c'est compris alors qu'il y
a des besoins de politique publique
évidentes
améliorer il y a des sujets massifs
lourds j'en évoqué quelques-uns et
demain pardon monsieur le sénateur je
suis obligé d'attendre demain
vous verrez dans nos notes un certain
nombre de pistes ils ont de
méthodologiques parce que nous ne
prêtons pas faire la place des autres et
donc monsieur le sénateur Gérard Longuet
le premier allié c'est peut-être le
Parlement c'est peut-être vous dans
votre mission d'évaluation justement
et en toute hypothèse il faut ouvrir ce
débat il y a eu des Assises des finances
politiques je réponds à une question qui
m'a été posée aussi
je suis allé j'y suis intervenu
je dis bienvenue à des assises l'idée
qu'on débattent enfin dans ce pays des
finances publiques tant mieux je dis
aussi
tant mieux quand le gouvernement met
comme mot d'ordre le désendettement et
il était temps c'est une nécessité et je
dis tant mieux quand il y a les annonces
d'économie parce qu'elles sont
indispensables si on veut passer le cap
mais disons-le aussi
pas entre nous puisque c'est public mais
je le dis publiquement des assises ça
peut pas être une demi-journée passée
ensemble et des mesures budgétaires
si on veut
une démarche plus ambitieuse il faut une
revue durable et une revue partagée avec
de la transparence et avec du travail
sur les suites d'impact et donc
sur le sénateur monsieur le ministre il
n'est point besoin d'espérer pour
entreprendre et le rôle de la Cour c'est
d'enfoncer son clou et de faire son
chemin après le rôle du système
politique dans lequel nous ne sommes pas
monsieur sur la République nous ne
sommes pas une institution politique
c'est d'aller plus loin et je pense que
c'est une nécessité je suis presque
frappé comme le fasse pas parce que à
refusé quelque chose d'intelligent et
nécessaire on fait des choses qui sont
moins intelligentes et plus
inconfortables et du coup on accroît le
degré d'insatisfaction de nos concitue
pardon d'avoir été un peu long sur ses
premières réponses mais au fond elle
résume assez bien je crois
l'ensemble de mon propos j'irai plus
vite sur le reste avec votre permission
monsieur le rapporteur général vous
m'avez interdit sur les lois de
programmation sectorielle
sur les assises j'ai répondu à Monsieur
Delahaye sur les études d'impact je
crois aussi pour ce qui concerne
les
le reste sur l'étude d'impact j'y
reviens les comptes publiés un référé en
2018 sur les études d'impact en matière
sociale cinq recommandations y sont
généralisables et je pense qu'elle
devrait être suivie d'assurer la
traçabilité des étapes de la prise de
décision de s'assurer que
l'expérimentation a été envisagée parmi
les options d'évaluer l'impact des
amendements budgétaires du gouvernement
d'intégrer dans l'étude d'impact les
objectifs chiffrés les indicateurs des
relations ultérieures et complété les
bases d'évaluation en cas de changement
substantiels du projet de loi pour ce
qui est de
des assises je crois avoir répondu aussi
sur les
les opérateurs madame vermeiller sur la
fonction publique encore une fois nous
ne prétendons pas avoir une réponse
budgétaire nous soulignons c'est que
c'est un objet qui ne doit pas échapper
à revue nous ne sommes pas nous en train
de faire cette évaluation précise pour
ce qui est l'inflation sous-jacente et
de l'inflation
est au cours elle est calculée hors
énergie or élément volatils
pour ce qui est les conséquences des
lois de règlement non votées elles sont
à la fois relativement mineures et
extrêmement importante elles sont
relativement mineures parce que la seule
conséquence juridique c'est la question
de l'affectation sur les comptes
spéciaux ceux-ci sont alors de droit
selon la Golf sinon le résultat est bien
sûr dans le bidon de l'État s'il n'est
pas affecté au report à nouveau mais il
a dessus je me permets d'attirer votre
attention Mesdames et les 16 heures il y
en a conséquences de moyens termes qui
peut être extrêmement lourde
qui est que à partir de 2024 donc à
partir du printemps prochain
l'absence de loi de règlement empêchera
le Conseil des finances publiques de
vérifier les écarts significatifs entre
le bois de règlement les objectifs du
loi de programmation finance publique
puisque là il y en a plus on nous a
retiré le tapis plus de loi 2018-2022
elle était obsolète mais l'existait à
partir de 2022 nous sommes nulle part
si le Haut Conseil ne peut plus faire ce
constat il pourrait ça dépendra de son
président mais pas que de lui
dire qu'il n'est pas en état de mon avis
pertinent et le Conseil constitutionnel
pourrait ça dépend de lui considérer que
l'absence d'avis du Conseil des finances
publiques
posent des problèmes on regarde la
Constitution des lois de finances c'est
pour ça que depuis des mois et des mois
je vous dis que l'absence d'une loi de
programmation de finance publique pose
un problème juridique éventuellement
majeur et que nous aurons ce rendez-vous
on va maintenant au moment de la
prochaine loi de règlement le conseil
dans l'hypothèse où il y aurait pas
d'autres programmation c'est pour ça
qu'il faut vraiment la voter à ce
moment-là se trouverait devant une
situation extrêmement nulleuse et
l'absence de loi de règlement poserait
aussi un problème voilà donc aujourd'hui
pas trop grave un peu plus tard plus
ennuyeux quand même très clairement
et donc je répondrai ainsi à Madame
Labarde cette question comme d'habitude
extrêmement pertinente sur les
évaluations indépendantes alors il y a
le rôle de la Cour des comptes sur
lequel vous n'avez interrogé et nous
essayons de pas être défaillant nous
avons une mission d'évaluation des
politiques publiques qui est inscrit
dans la Constitution
à tel point que comme premier président
de la Cour des comptes depuis mon
arrivée j'ai décidé d'augmenter la part
de l'évaluation de politique publique
dans nos ressources elle était 4-5%
quand je suis arrivé 7 8% aujourd'hui
elle sera de 20% 2025 mais nous ne
sommes pas les seuls je pense qu'il faut
jamais prétendre à l'hégémonie en la
matière jamais prétendre au monopole
encore moins et donc il y a aussi des
évaluations académiques d'ailleurs une
évaluation de politique de la Cour des
comptes ça se fait en collaboration avec
des labo académique
il y a 30 ou 40 labos en France qui ont
cette expertise qui la développe
d'ailleurs et c'est le travail en
permanence de la cour
nous avons publié 33 enquêtes ces
dernières années évaluatives mais nous
ne prenons pas faire une évolution
globale d'ailleurs personne ne le
pourrait il faudrait la créer un
organisme une taille je crois assez des
raisins où va la dépense publique je
dirais 58 milliards pour la charte de la
dette ou même ne l'oublions pas
28 puissants volume et par habitant
depuis 2000 l'essentiel de
l'augmentation est liée à l'évolution
des prestations sociales ça veut pas
dire qu'elles doivent être une cible
particulière mais le constat est là en
matière d'augmentation c'est là où se
trouve la source majeure sur les
collectivités de territoriales je crois
avoir répondu à beaucoup d'entre vous
sur sur la question de Madame briquet
sur les recettes
vous savez que la Cour des comptes sa
compétence porte avant tout sur les
dépenses plus que sur les recettes sur
les recettes nous ne sommes pas démunis
puisque je précise également un autre
organisme qui s'appelle le Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires
mais je vais vous donner un sentiment
qu'il n'est pas extrêmement nouveau
puisque monsieur Dominati m'appelait
replonger dans une autre vie je me
souviens qu'il y a 10 ans quasi
exactement j'avais prononcé une phrase
en tant que mis des finances sur le
ras-le-bol fiscal je veux leur placer
dans son contexte il y avait eu à
l'époque une loi de finance puis une loi
de financement de sécurité sociale puis
de loi de finance rectificative qui à
chaque fois avec comporté des mesures
fiscales importantes rendu sans doute
nécessaire par l'impératif de diminuer
les déficit plutôt que de taper sur les
dépenses mais point trop n'en faut une
fois ça va deux fois bonjour les dégâts
et je suis finalement madame la
sénatrice
tout à fait fidèle à cette idée à savoir
que quand on a 44 ou 45% de prélèvement
obligatoire
disons pour être modéré que le maniement
de l'arme fiscale comme instrument de
régulation conjoncturel doit être
vraiment utiliser qu'une grande prudence
et qu'une forme de stabilité s'impose
parce que derrière ça il y a le
consentement à l'impôt de tous
sans doute des plus fortunés mais aussi
des couches populaires
n'imaginons pas que c'est plus populaire
moi j'étais pas élu à Neuilly ou cet
arrondissement de Paris mais dans le dos
à Sochaux quand j'étais député on
n'aimait pas beaucoup le montation des
impôts quand on était ouvrier là-bas et
donc soyons comme très prudent ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut s'interdire
l'usage de l'arme fiscale pour des
questions d'allocation économiques ou
pour de la fiscalité écologique par
exemple question tout à fait ouverte ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il faut s'interdire
l'usage de fiscalité comme instrument de
distribution mais je dirais si l'idée
c'est la régulation conjoncturelle si
vous voulez réduire les déficits je ne
recommanderai pas d'utiliser l'arme
fiscale comme étant celle du comble
voilà il y a d'autres manières il y a
pas que les dépenses en effet il y a le
lutte contre la fraude il y a d'abord la
croissance potentielle et l'augmentation
des recettes il y a la question des
dépenses fiscales sur lesquelles nous
allons en effet produire une note de
main sont tout de même de 14 milliards
d'euros sans tout dévoiler je dirais que
nous tirons l'idée qu'il faut d'abord un
plafond qui soit réellement contraignant
fiscale qu'il faut en faire la revue
régulière et qu'elle devrait être bornée
dans le temps avoir des centaines de
dépenses fiscales qui continuent sans
jamais être évalués sans jamais être
borné ça pose quand même je me
semble-t-il à très gros problème enfin
j'en termine par la question de monsieur
le sénateur Calmette qui je ne sais pas
s'il a fait volontairement peut-être que
oui quand même mettons une perche j'ai
répondu sur la partie évaluation en
général mais il y a cette commission apt
qui ne concerne pas principalement votre
commission des finances mais qui pour
moi un casse-tête depuis deux ans dont
je ne suis absolument pas responsable
pour les commissions qui est placée
auprès de la Cour des comptes
comme le Haut Conseil comme le Conseil
des premiers obligatoires
c'est ce qu'on appelle une institution
associée par législateur le Sénat
d'ailleurs dans sa grande sagesse avait
voulu aligner le système sur celui du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques ce
qu'il a raison même comme premier
président de la Cour des comptes
présidents de l'institution indépendante
et donc pas une administration je ne
fais pas le secrétaire administratif de
quoi que ce soit donc tout institution
qui se trouve à la Cour des Comptes est
présidé par le Premier Président ça veut
pas dire qu'il est le dictateur je suis
pas le dictateur du Conseil des finances
publiques il y a des membres pluralistes
qui sont nommés par le président du
Sénat par le
qui ont des finances par ça des
académiques et on débat très bien et je
dis depuis deux ans de manière logique
observons le parallélisme des formes ce
qui d'ailleurs ce que vous aviez voté
dans votre commission de la faire
étrangères avec une très grande sagesse
pour les raisons assez obscures c'est
refusé et donc nous ne parvenons pas à
le mettre en place ce que je trouve
je le dis honnêtement absurde j'ai les
crédits j'ai les gens pour s'en occuper
il suffit de nommer les députés les
sénateurs et de procéder de manière
logique tout ira bien je ne sais pas
pourquoi ça ne se fait pas je le
regrette je n'en suis pas peut-être avec
vous été destinataire de quelques
courriers que j'ai pas du tout vous êtes
membre de la Commission
ah ben je vous ferai passer ça avec
grand plaisir puisque j'ai écrit à vos
collègues sénateurs de la Commission de
l'étrangères et vous comprendrez tout à
fait l'objet de la querelle et j'ajoute
un peu de mon nid voilà
c'est reproduit ce loi de règlement
monsieur le
un problème tout à fait mineur
maintenant mais tout à fait considérable
en 2024 si nous auraient la situation
actuelle en matière de programmation de
financement de l'impasse ou bien merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'occasion de ces précisions merci
monsieur le Premier Président et donc
demain nous serons toutes oui pour voir
les propositions domaines par domaine
sur 9 domaines nous allons nous allons
vous les adresser bien sûr merci
beaucoup demain matin
merci en tout cas et je vous rappelle